two kinds of writing creating and
shaping
there are two kinds of writing um and
every piece of writing
uses both kinds it's not like somebody
only does creating and somebody only
does the shaping
every writer has to get used to sort of
a uh
over and over again process um creating
what i call creating and it's just the
the stuff that comes out what some
people call the vomit draft or
the um the experience of just
trying to imagine stuff and write down
what you think
trying to put yourself in a scene or
think what would they say next
and write it down you're accessing
something that truly humanity has no
idea
what it is or where it comes from i
don't know if it's something that other
creatures have but people have this
weird ability
to make stuff up uh it's essentially
dreaming
you you think of a story or a character
or a moment or a scene or a line
and you don't you can't really say where
it comes from
uh and this is every artist
in history has experience has described
the same experience
of i was trying to write this thing and
this line just came to me this scene
this twist
whatever it is it just comes to you and
the more that you can get used to the um
need to let it happen however it happens
to create without any judgment at all
without any criticism
without any fear saying anything that
comes out of me at this moment
is fine and to be able to sustain that
and do that for a bit of time
and get something down and to get used
to the experience
of making that written down
feeling free with the words even if
they're bad even if if you're
bad at typing they're going to be
misspelled doesn't matter what matters
is that they
you grab them from that mysterious place
and you get them
on the paper that's creating but then
almost always it's going to need some
shaping some editing some rethinking
writing rewriting and that second
shaping part is where you say clean up
all the typos
break that long sentence into two short
ones make those two short ones into one
long one
that word there that's really vague what
do i mean when i say
baffled baffle is actually pretty
specific but you know what i mean
that do you start to think the way
someone who's
not you would read it and whether they
would get the experience you're trying
to give them
and then you start to be mechanical
about it there's tricks you can use
putting
the punch line at the end putting the
set up at the beginning
finding funny sounding words for funny
lines there's all these tricks of the
trade
that goes in the shaping part when
you're shaping
you're spending a lot of time being
critical
um and trying to when you're critical
what you're trying to do is
i like to think of critical as making
the best of
not saying bad i'm not critical of it
i am wow there's a funny bit in that but
this is getting in the way so
critically i'm going to get rid of the
stuff that's in the way of the good
i like the good what's important about
being critical is that you're doing it
to improve what it is trying to be
not make it into something else and
certainly not just
slam it down the editing part of you the
rewriting part of you
is the second part of the process
usually
it goes back and forth several times
sometimes
you get weirdly creative while you're
editing a new line comes to you and then
you
so you're sort of doing a micro switch
editing editing oh the new line creative
oh
back to editing and that process goes
over and over
most writers i know they tend to set
aside a separate mood
you know i know i'm going to have to do
seven days of
creating creating craving i'm never
gonna look back at what i wrote
and i'm just gonna every day set aside
an hour
throw it down and then go you know make
myself a nice lunch
then for another seven days i'm going to
look at what i wrote take a big deep
breath
start to break it down start to do the
work stretch a little
go back to it and that process over and
over
will make for great writing
do you think too many writers are
focused on positive feedback
instead of writing something that can
actually be made
that's interesting um actually i do
think that
we have developed a script reading
industry within the industry and
that has sort of become a kind of i
don't know what the term is for like if
you've got a river
and it suddenly gets like a little
backwater and things get stuck in there
instead of going with the flow but
that's
there is that
people who are writing scripts are
unfortunately
mostly writing them to be judged by
people whose jobs is
to read them that could be professional
script readers and critics
it can also be anyone who is an
executive or a producer
their job is to read a script and try
and figure out if that script is going
to be producible
but still they're they're working on the
script many many people who are in those
fields
don't know anything about production
they don't know anything about making
a movie and in fact when i say movie i
mean movie or show or
filmed entertainment of any kind
the most important thing for a
screenwriter because it's a particular
kind of writer
is that you are writing for production
there is no
value to your writing until it is
produced someone may pay you money which
is
value in the sense that they think it's
going to get produced
but truthfully the value is if that
script
can be acted and directed and edited and
released
and there's different qualities which
are valuable
to the people doing the acting directing
editing than
the readers and you need to be able to
please both
because you can't get to the production
people without going
through the readers
so i would say you need to learn all the
advice about how to please a reader and
what they're looking for and what they
the rules they have and
everybody tells you different rules but
know as many rules as you can
but still it's very important to
understand what happens when a script
gets made if you can
make it yourself write a script for the
purpose
of making it yourself just so that you
learn what happens
when an actor has to say lines one of
the things that happens is you'll learn
most of the lines that you wrote were
probably information
in other words you were thinking i need
the audience to know this thing so i'll
write a line where somebody says it in
some way
but what the actor and the director and
the editor need
is for the character to need to say
something
totally different the character has to
need to say the information
if they don't need to say it it's not
going to work for the actor and the
director
the only way that you can learn that is
by having actors and directors work
with your script if you are a diy type
of person
try it find a way to you know at this
point you can do it on
your phone you can get a bunch of actors
from the nearby community theater or
college
write something that's appropriate to
their ability of talent
and try it out it's going to take you
some time it's going to be some
heartache there's going to be some
arguments
but you will learn how your script
is transformed by the production process
what
works and doesn't work and that is
incredibly valuable to everyone who
eventually will make the movie
and if you can learn that stuff by
and you can pretty much only learn it by
doing it
then you will be a screenwriter who's
making something
not just to get approval but to actually
get made and be good
so by running these lines by these
actors and
filming it with your phone you're
finding out what's filler
in the dialogue and what is an actor or
character wanting something portraying
that to another character who also wants
something
what it really will come down to is
you'll learn what dramatic action is
because dialogue is action when somebody
speaks
actually in real life too you're trying
to do something like
when you go to a counter and say may i
have a pack of cigarettes
well don't say that say say may i have a
club soda and a lottery ticket yeah
um when you say that it's because you're
trying to accomplish something when you
say to someone
i love you or i don't love you anymore
it's because you're trying to accomplish
something you're trying to
make something happen or get something
you're trying to change your
relationship with them you're trying to
get something some of them to do
something all
dialogue should be action that's what an
actor needs to play and that's what a
director needs to direct
is that almost every writer you'll meet
especially the ones who have not been in
production will think in terms of
information this dialogue is conveying
this information
and they can make it sound nice but if
it's not actually
action if the character is not trying to
change something in that moment
it's not going to play by the way the
other thing i wanted to say was
i'm a fan of diy and i think that we
should demystify it
the point of diy filmmaking is mostly
not to get your big break and to have it
sell for a billion dollars
it's to get experience it's the it's the
same thing that the the
the ten thousand hours you know uh
malcolm gladwell
in um uh oh gosh i can't remember the
name of the book now
malcolm gladwell uh publicize this
phrase
um outliers is malcolm gladwell's
outliers
ten thousand hours is what it takes to
be real mastery
of any particular thing you're doing
it took me like 30 000 because i'm
really stubborn
and slow but um
that process for a screenwriter
has to include the production and um
what happened was the the indie industry
blew up in the the 80s and 90s over
somebody makes a 3 000 movie and it
sells a billion dollars and
and they're great for the rest of their
career um and so everyone started making
movies for that
aim for every one of those that was
huge there were thousands that
lost all their money and the important
thing to know about diy
is you're going to lose all your money
the you might as well
grab a lottery ticket to try and make
money off of of indie filmmaking
but that's not the point the point is to
do the work
and get it to an audience to get in
production and if you don't feel like
diying yourself
there are people who are wanting to diy
who can't write
and they will love you if you just want
to write and give it to them
so the important thing about that is the
same thing that the 10 000 hours taught
the beatles when they went to hamburg
and they had to play
god knows eight hour sets every day for
weeks and weeks on end
supposedly that's when they got good
the work they were doing was not
necessarily their best work but they
were
producing their work and putting it in
front of an audience and doing it again
the next day that's the important thing
that screenwriters are not given the
opportunity to do
you're not going to be given that
opportunity so you should take it
yourself
do it a nice safe way like i said if
you're a writer and you don't feel like
producing
find people out there they want good
scripts
when you were attempt for those 12 years
was there one story that you really
clung to
of your own of your own writing that you
thought this is going to be it
or were you constantly working on new
things well i did have this one script
that kept on
getting passed around and people liked
for those 10 years and eventually it did
sell so
that that for those who out there yeah
10 years it can still
sell and frankly after that 10 years 10
years after that it was still being
shown and people were showing interest
in it
so that's one of the important things
that you should remember when you write
something
and you're thinking this will be my
break it might be your break in the
sense that people recognize your talent
through it and they never make that but
it becomes quote a show script
that's a perfectly valuable thing i got
a lot of show
scripts i thought they were going to be
big hits i thought they were going to
make me a fortune
but they were just something that
somebody read and said wow
you're a good writer why don't you write
this thing that i think will make money
um that's still a valid reason to write
a script and
the script still exists you know
somebody doesn't buy it it's not like it
gets burned somebody else later on might
like it
you